this is sort of a funny detail about the
presidential transition typically during
the inauguration
there's this few hour period during
which furniture is swapped out at the
white house for the incoming president
artwork has changed there's a little bit
of redecorating that's done and
it's you know all happening very very
quickly because of the coronavirus
pandemic
this time around there's an extra detail
which is that joe biden has already made
plans
to spray down the entire white house
with disinfectant
in that interim period after trump
leaves and before joe biden arrives
as you probably know the white house has
been suffering a plague
of coveted infections that includes
trump himself
and many other people i won't list them
so they're going to go in and hit
the doorknobs and everything and for me
this is more about the optics and the
poetic meaning of disinfecting the white
house from trump because
listen we learned remember early on in
the pandemic where people were
bleaching a groceries including just
like boxed groceries where you could
just open the box and
anyway and then we found out that the
surface transmission was really quite
low
that was probably a bit overblown um so
for me
this is this is not really about
spraying down
the white house with disinfectant
misting disinfectant
to literally prevent someone who works
for biden from catching the virus from a
surface
v via someone who works for trump for me
it's more about the poetic meaning
of going through the white house misting
disinfectant everywhere
it's more about the metaphor of
getting rid of trump and his failed
response to the pandemic
you still love to see it the visual is
going to think about is hilarious
but it's more for me about cleaning the
white house not literally of trump's
germs
but of the incompetent leadership of the
virus i'm calling this
fumigate i'm not even a dad and i was
able to tell that joke
i was actually thinking though um so
first my thought was maybe biden should
sleep somewhere else a few days and give
it
48 72 hours before walking into the
white house
but the truth is trump may well be gone
by then this is the other story and
we've been covering this for the last
seven to ten days
it's still unclear whether donald trump
is going to stick around and actually go
to the inauguration
one other possibility is he will fly out
right before the
inauguration directly to a rally at
which he will continue to claim he won
or maybe even announce his 2024
candidacy that would be
completely corrosive to democracy he
might also head to florida in just about
10 or 15 days
for christmas and new year and just not
come back to washington dc that's
another speculation
we really don't know and we don't care
as long as he leaves now
if i were biden to be safe i would spray
i would treat for bed bugs i would check
for
electronic bugs as well check for false
paneled walls
check melania's rose garden for
listening devices
put the solar panels back on i would do
the whole thing
if i were joe biden and think about how
quickly
things have changed where at the
beginning of this pandemic
before any of them even remotely
accepted this might be a big thing
republicans were joking about wearing
gas masks remember matt gates
wearing a big gas mask on the floor of
congress he ended up getting the virus
they were making fun of china having
trucks spraying disinfectant
and just months later the incoming
president
is going to have disinfectant sprayed in
much the same manner
throughout the white house to clean it
from the outgoing president
things change very quickly my only
concern is let's start figuring this out
let's get competent leadership we know
that joe biden is going to mandate masks
at federal buildings
we know joe biden is going to ask
americans to wear masks for a hundred
days
we are hoping that we will start getting
five six seven percent of the u.s
population vaccinated
each month hopefully starting this month
maybe only a few percent this month
and five six seven eight percent in
january
another five to eight percent in
february and we're going to we're going
to start
um hopefully the economic recovery will
come with it we're going to talk about
second coronavirus stimulus
we're going to be here and there's going
to be so much to do but this transition
is metaphorical in as much of a sense as
it is literal
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at dpakman and we've got a great
show for you today
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a
silky lightweight cloth that feels great
on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over 150 dollars you can
get there by going to davidpakman.com
the link is under this video and you can
save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david